day two in summercand and more
admissions from Vladimir Putin as he met
with leaders from the Shanghai
cooperation organization that powerful
counterparts aren't too happy with the
situation in Ukraine this exchange with
India's prime minister who told Mr Putin
this was not an era of War
I know
about your position on the conflict in
Ukraine and I know about your concerns I
know of that you share these concerns
and we want all of this to end as soon
as possible
but the other party the leadership of
Ukraine
has claimed that they refused to engage
in negotiating process they said that
they want to achieve their objectives as
they say on the battlefield militarily
and then finally more than a week after
Ukraine recaptured swathes of territory
in the northeast of the country the
Russian president's response to the
recent setbacks foreign
though they didn't shy away from asking
what everyone wants to know
this was a way for Vladimir Putin to
signal to his people first and foremost
that they have nothing to worry about
that all is going to plan but what was
striking was to hear how his answers
were riddled with this anti-western
paranoia almost a persecution complex
this deeply held conviction that the
West is out to destroy the Russian State
via Ukraine and that's what compelled
him to act
and though he got no outright
expressions of support for his operation
in Ukraine from his greatest pal at the
summit Xi Jinping the Chinese Premier
expressed similar fears about murky
foreign forces
foreign
as an act of self-defense does not wash
with the west and it does not seem to
resonate with the rest either what's
clear from two days of symmetry though
is that Vladimir Putin is not changing
course
dynamagne Sky News Moscow